after an islamic extremist takes
hostages at a synagogue the fbi
announces it's puzzlement over motive a
new poll shows half of americans
disappointed with joe biden and
republican glenn younkin takes office in
virginia i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressivevpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first if you're in a business
you need to be as efficient as humanly
possible you really need to know how to
market right marketing is a big thing
and getting in touch with your customers
is a big thing and this is why if you
own a business you really need to be
using text local businesses everywhere
turn to podium to do this podium makes
every interaction as easy as sending a
text everything that makes your business
great can get done faster podium isn't
just a better way to communicate it's a
better way to do everything gathering
reviews collecting payments even
marketing to your customers podium makes
it all as easy as pressing send whenever
you receive a call from a telemarketer
have you ever picked one up however if
somebody texts you do you sometimes
respond the answer is yes you won't just
free up more time you will grow your
business and get more done with podium
you'll close deals with customers before
the competition even has a chance to
call them back and certainly before
anybody picks up that call join more
than 100 000 businesses that already use
podiums to streamline their customer
interactions get started for free at
podium.com shapiro or sign up for a paid
podium account get a free credit card
reader restrictions apply that's
podium.com
shapiro
p-o-d-i-u-m dot com
shapiro to get started alrighty so
over sabbath there was a hostage
situation at a synagogue in a place
called collieville which is near dallas
texas and it started with an islamist
radical going into
this synagogue and demanding the freeing
of a terrorist
and it ended with all of the hostages
freed and the terrorists shot dead the
hostage taker shot dead which is the way
all of these situations should end and
god bless the folks from swat who put
this guy down and thank god that nobody
innocent was injured in this process
well according to the local paper the
fort worth star telegram the fbi on
sunday identified the hostage taker in
the standoff at a colleyville synagogue
as a 44 year old british citizen by
british citizen they mean the guy is a
radical muslim from britain
i don't do the names of terrorists on
this program i don't do the names of
mass shooters on this program because
they are looking for notoriety so we do
not provide that but this guy was a
radical islamist he could be heard
speaking during a live stream that
broadcast a portion of the 11 hour
standoff died saturday night after a
hostage rescue team breached the
building the four hostages were unarmed
authorities said saturday that the
hostage taker was killed in the shooting
did not answer a question about whether
he was shot by law enforcement or if the
gunshot was self-inflicted the man
claimed to have explosives according to
statements he made on live stream videos
president biden did call this an act of
terror he said there were apparently no
explosives
this
particular person was demanding the
freeing
of a woman who is a terrorist i mean
she's been in prison she's going to be
in prison for the next several decades
before this facebook's livestream was
taken offline about 2 p.m an angry man
could be heard ranting at times talking
about religion i love the the star
telegrams
description of this ranting about
judaism and islam would be the answer to
this
the hostage taker apparently was
singularly focused on one issue he
repeatedly mentioned his sister and
islam and used profanities hilariously
everybody was like well he's not
actually sisters with the terrorists yes
i know
okay in religious communities
particularly islamic religious
communities this is just true in
religious communities all over the place
people sometimes call each other brother
and sister it's not like it doesn't mean
they're literally brother and sister
he apparently said once i have my sister
here let me tell you i will not take
these four guys out i swear by allah
so islamist radical trying to free a
terrorist this person was trying to free
a person named afiya siddiqui a
pakistani neuroscientist who attracted
the attention of american law
enforcement in the years after the
september 11th attacks
top fbi and justice department described
her as an al-qaeda operative and
facilitator at an a2004 news conference
in which they warned of intelligence
showing that al-qaeda plans an attack in
the coming months for years supporters
have called for the release of siddiqui
she was a neuroscientist who's an mit
graduate she's currently being held at a
women's prison in fort worth she was
convicted in 2010 on charges related to
the attempted murder and assault of u.s
officers and employees in afghanistan
two years earlier the hostage taker said
a few times he didn't want anyone heard
he mentioned his own kids he said
repeatedly he believed he was going to
die a couple of his kids were just
arrested
in great britain
this person was apparently from the
blackburn area of lancashire
a rabbi with the simon wiesenthal center
said in a statement sunday they believe
the hostage taker was able to enter the
synagogue by posing as a homeless man
and this was a synagogue so they said
okay come on in and then it turns out
that he was in fact a hostage taker now
what is amazing about this particular
situation is that it is not particularly
surprising the reason that is not
particularly surprising and the reason
that synagogues all over the united
states have security is because there
are a lot of people who target jews
because they are anti-semites because
they hate jews it is not a giant giant
shock and this particular hostage taking
shouldn't have been supremely surprising
at least over the issue of afiya
siddiqui because this has been a cause
celeb in the islamist community for a
very very long time as well as among
left-wing allies
national review had a piece
by sam west drop in september
titled islamists exploit western
progressives handwringing to support
their own
since siddiqui was known as lady
al-qaeda
and is supposedly a victim of the
security states cruelty siddiqi earned
the moniker in 2004 after the fbi named
her as one of seven senior al qaeda
figures plotting attacks against the
united states fbi director robert
mueller described her at the time as an
al-qaeda operative and facilitator years
later siddiqui was captured in
afghanistan upon her arrest
investigators found handwritten notes
that referred to a mass casualty attack
and that listed various locations in the
united states including plummet island
the empire state building the statue of
liberty wall street and the brooklyn
bridge other notes in siddiqui's
possession referred to the construction
of dirty bombs and discussed various
ways to attack enemies including by
destroying reconnaissance drones using
underwater bombs and deploying gliders
in the lead-up to her trial siddiqui who
hated jews demanded the jews be excluded
from the jury claimed claiming the
entire prosecution had been orchestrated
by unnamed jews she was sentenced in
2010 to 86 years in prison after the
jury found that siddiqui attempted to
murder americans serving in afghanistan
as well as their afghan colleagues since
her conviction a bunch of jihadist
groups have demanded her release
apparently the taliban offered to
exchange siddiqui for captured us army
sergeant beau bergdahl isis also offered
to exchange prisoners as did al qaeda
indeed the pakistani regime has long
been a leading voice in the call to
release siddiqui with tacit support from
elements of the regime for jihadist
group such as the taliban and yaishi
mohammed
sadiq was linked to both groups
pakistani prime minister yusuf gaza
gillani once referred to siddiqui as
daughter of the nation
siddiqui was a beacon to islamists
everywhere european jihadist thai
charitable convoys to syria named
vehicles after her in 2018 one jihadist
even attempted an attack on the federal
medical center carswell in fort worth in
an attempt to freer so this is not even
the last time
this is not the first time that somebody
has attempted to free lady al-qaeda by
by engaging in violent action
a wide variety of lawful american
islamist groups and clerics many of whom
have grown increasingly close to
pakistan over the past decade also now
campaign on siddiqui's behalf
this includes a bunch of major american
islamist organizations
okay so this has been sort of a cause
celeb among left-wing advocates as well
as islamist advocates for quite a while
in the united states
and yet the narrative in the middle of
this particular hostage taking is that
we had no clue what was happening and in
fact anybody who suggested this might
have to do with the innate anti-semitism
of islamism
is uh is is somehow islamophobic now
this is a bizarre contention because i
was
actually texting with uh a muslim friend
of mine on saturday night and he was
saying that he was praying obviously for
the freeing of the jews who'd been taken
hostage because it turns out that a huge
number of muslims are not in favor of
people taking jews hostage in order to
free terrorists i know shocker shocked
there are many muslims who are not in
favor of this but
for a for a wide swath of the left-wing
media and for many of the muslim voices
promoted by the mainstream media the
idea that this has anything to do with
islamism which is a which is a radical
form of islam that unfortunately has
many adherents around the world that if
you mention this sort of stuff this
makes you an islamophobe
no
it does not
and one of the people who was pushing
the left-wing perspective was wajahat
ali who used to be on cnn he tweeted
you're about to hear some ugly and
vicious islamophobia and anti-muslim
bigotry this weekend from elected
officials commentators and even
mainstream media hope i'm wrong people
will use it to divide jewish and muslim
communities for their political agenda
don't fall for it yes whenever jews are
taken hostage by a radical muslim the
real victims are muslims
obviously islamophobia is obviously the
thing we ought to worry about and this
has been a pattern in american public
life with regard to a wide variety of
crimes for a very long time if you are
identified by the left in the united
states as a victim group if a member of
that supposed victim group perpetrates a
crime we are supposed to pretend that it
is not a crime or that it is a mystery
we've had the same thing happening with
regard to anti-semitism for years in new
york and new jersey when a black hebrew
israelite attempted to murder a bunch of
jewish children in new jersey now she
did kill some people in new jersey it
was treated as a non-national story for
more than about 25 seconds when a white
supremacist targets jews at the tree of
life synagogue in pittsburgh that's a
national story because there you have a
member of a quote unquote not victimized
group attacking jews or a more
victimized group therefore the
intersectional hierarchy has been upheld
the victimized group was victimized the
victimizing group was the victimizer and
therefore that is a newsworthy story
however it is not newsworthy when a poor
black person attacks a jew in
williamsburg
if that happens that is not a story and
if a muslim attacks a jew that's also
not a story because according to the
left for some odd reason radical muslims
attacking jews
is somehow
a story of the victimized group
attacking the victimizing group now just
on a pure kind of global power level you
have to question why that would possibly
be the case
there are well over a billion muslims on
planet earth their grand total at
current of like 15 million jews on the
planet
muslims are in control of some 57 58
countries
on planet earth jews are in control of
one
a jews are a minority in every country
except for israel muslims are a majority
in a wide variety of countries
and yet somehow according to the left
whenever there is a conflict between jew
and muslim it must be the jews who are
the perpetrators and if it's the reverse
then we have to pretend that it's not
happening or we have to downplay it we
have to pretend it's some sort of enigma
wrapped in a mystery
again this has nothing to do with the
idea that all muslims are anti-semitic
or all muslims are
are terrorists or anything remotely like
that that's not true
what it does have to do with is left's
willingness to cover up crimes because
it does not back the narrative that they
wish to purvey which is that in the
intersectional hierarchy jews are the
victimizers when posited next to muslims
and this also has to do by the way with
the with the wild anti-israel sentiment
on the left that has now cropped up
you know the the re there are a lot of
people who wonder why is it that the
left is so radically anti-israel these
days considering that israel is
significantly more in line with a lot of
the social views of the left than the
muslim world is
in israel famously you can live openly
as a gay person in israel
in israel women have tremendous amounts
of rights israel's very liberal with
regard to women's rights israel has very
liberal abortion law you would figure
that the left would be very much in
favor of israel and yet not so why well
because essentially leftism is now a
class conspiracy theory whereby anybody
who is successful violated somebody who
is unsuccessful which is how they got
successful
well that theory sounds a lot like
anti-semitic conspiracy theories about
jews in control of the media using
control of world finance jews in control
of the power centers and therefore jews
must have victimized somebody in order
to achieve their power
the leftist narrative as applied to jews
more specifically is the same as the
anti-semitic narrative which is why
there is this stream crossing and why we
have to the minute the jews are taken
hostage at a a dallas synagogue a huge
part of the media is immediately like
this is gonna be about islamophobia
isn't it it's gonna be this is why the
democratic party when ilhan omar who's a
radical anti-semite when she says a
bunch of jew-hating crap this is why the
democratic party immediately has to pass
a resolution condemning both
anti-semitism and islamophobia as though
one can't be condemned without
condemning the other
it's absurd and unfortunately this has
bled up into the major institutions of
american life and anti-semitism can only
be taken seriously by the left when the
person who is purveying the
anti-semitism is a white person that is
the only time it is worth noting
which of course is bizarre since the
vast majority of anti-semitism pervade
on planet earth right now is not
pervaded by white people
i hate to break it to folks but that is
not the case okay white
if there are white supremacists they're
incredibly dangerous hey there are white
supremacists who hate jews they're
incredibly dangerous i know this
personally because the fbi arrested a
white supremacist about four years ago
who was targeting my family and that
person is now in jail
okay so i i get it
but the vast majority of anti-semitism
on planet earth right now is not being
purveyed by white supremacists because
that's a very small number of white
supremacists the vast majority of of
anti-semitism in terms of hate crime in
terms of action in terms of broad policy
that is being purveyed is being purveyed
by radical muslims
or in domestic context it's being
pervaded by people of color okay this is
true in new york
but you can't you can't pay attention to
that because anti-semitism only matters
when the people who are promoting the
anti-semitism are people that the left
has decided are members of the power
class
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you're spending too much money on
gas because everybody is spending too
much money on gas these days well if you
could save money by downloading a free
app and then just using it why would you
not do this this is where get upside
comes in my listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up just download that
free get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
shapiro get a bonus 25 cents per gallon
on your first fill up that's up to 50
cents cash back don't pay full price of
the pump anymore get cash back using it
get upside just download the app for
free use promo code shapiro to get up to
50 cents per gallon cash back on your
very first tank of gas some people who
drive a lot are making as much as two to
three hundred bucks a year in cash back
and there is no catch the cash back gets
added directly to your account you can
cash out anytime it's your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon and
other brands just download that free get
upside app news promo code shapiro get
up to 50 cents per gallon cash back on
your very first tank of gas that is
promo code shapiro go check them out
right now get that get upside app and
use the promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your very
first tank of gas okay so
the response from the federal government
the immediate response was bewildering
to say the least the fbi came out and
they made a statement see if you can
spot the problem with this particular
statement
we do believe from our engagement with
this subject that he was singularly
focused on one issue
and it was not specifically related to
the jewish community but we're
continuing to work to find motive and we
will continue on that path what did it
have to do with the jewish community
what are they
it's part of a broader anti-semitic
conspiracy theory held by radical
muslims the jews are in control of all
the levers of power lady al-qaeda
literally said it at her trial she
literally said the jews are behind this
so is it a giant shock that a radical
islamist decided to invade a synagogue
and hold jews at gunpoint saying that
somehow they had the magical weather
controlling power to free terrorists
i mean
it's not a surprise in any sort of way
but we have to pretend that we don't
know
by the way it doesn't just apply to jews
this sort of logic remember that the
military for years denied that the fort
hood massacre which was carried out by a
radical islamist that that had anything
to do with radical islam they said it
was sort of they called it a workplace
violence incident
because for the left any time there's a
member of a victimized population who
commits a crime
we cannot we cannot acknowledge the
hatred implicit therein
because to do so would recognize that
sometimes the quote-unquote victimizing
group is actually the victim group and
we can't ever ever have that
okay joe biden did some of the same
stuff he said well you know we kind of
know why he targeted the synagogue but
at the same time then he buys it back
because this is what joe biden does
well
no i don't we don't have i don't think
there is
sufficient information to know about
uh
why he
targeted that synagogue why he insisted
on the release of someone who's been in
prison for over uh 10 years why he was
engaged why he
was using anti-semitic and anti-israeli
comments uh i i we just don't have
enough facts we don't have enough facts
i'm how about he's a radical islamist
that's that's the only fact you need
which is true
i think that's it
done but he can't acknowledge that right
why is it so tough too no i don't know
honestly guys don't understand this if
it had been a white supremacist who had
gone into a synagogue and shot a bunch
of people do you think joe biden would
be there like we don't know enough to
know his motive he'd just say he's a
white supremacist of course he was there
to shoot jews like what why why is that
in any way a mystery but somehow again
it always comes back to the narrative
always in forever and then joe biden
turned and swiveled and he blamed guns
or something which i'm sorry come on
come on the guy bought the gun illegally
by the way as joe biden acknowledges
shabbat acknowledges this guy literally
bought the gun off the street he didn't
walk into a gun shop and then buy it
just over the counter
the idea of background checks are
critical but you can't stop something
like this if someone is on the street
buying something from somebody else on
the street
except that there's two there's so many
guns that have been sold of late it's
just ridiculous and uh and it's because
of the failure us to focus as hard as we
should and as consistently should
on gun purchases gun sales ghost guns a
whole range of things that i'm trying to
do okay that would have nothing to do
with uh stopping what happened
in uh in
colleyville like that that's that's a
that's a that's a ridiculous ridiculous
statement by joe biden again
he does not want to acknowledge the
reality meanwhile the new york times
didn't even put this on the front page
so the new york times front page the day
after has a lot of stories
including
a woman killed after a shove in the
subway and vladimir putin could cause
trouble not just in ukraine but in the
west
but uh nothing on the front page about
the the attempt to kill four jews uh in
in dallas after a 12-hour standoff no
nothing nothing there
kind of kind of amazing do you think of
white supremacists that might have made
the front page you think maybe just a
little bit now what's amazing about all
of this from a jewish perspective you
know as an orthodox jew and someone's
deeply encountered in the jewish
community one of the things that is
perfectly obvious from all of this is
that there are so many jews there's a
commentary to some of my jewish brothers
and sisters there are a lot of jews who
think that by dissociating from the
jewish community or who think that by
ripping on israel that somehow they're
going to buy the love of anti-semites
all over the world i'm not saying that
you have to take a wildly right-wing
position on the same issues that i do
i'm not saying you have to mirror my
perspective all i'm saying is that for
anti-semites a jew is a jew is a jew and
it does not matter how much you say that
israel is bad or a quote-unquote
apartheid immigration no matter how much
you fib about that or lie about that no
matter how much you attempt to buy the
love of of leftists who supposedly will
treat you decently
the minute that you are victimized by
somebody who is higher than you on the
totem of intersectionality on the totem
pole of intersection now the minute that
happens you become baggage
the the this particular congregation is
a very far-left congregation politically
speaking right is there a reform
congregation the rabbi at this
congregation is guy named charlie
citroen walker
and he's a very progressive dude
according to forward.com
he was he was a person who was
constantly holding iftar dinners and he
arrived at beth israel in 2006 shortly
after his ordination from hebrew union
college jewish institute of religion he
was this he was the small reformed
congregation's first full-time rabbi he
is the kind of person who took his
wife's name as like a hyphenated name
he's a very
left-leaning guy for sure his wife works
for a group called the multicultural
alliance the couple has two daughters
the younger of whom became bat mitzvah
during the pandemic before starting
rabbinical school he worked at focus
hope a civil and human rights
organization in detroit and at a soup
kitchen and food pantry in amherst
massachusetts
and there there's a lot of talk about
his his positions with regard to israel
which are extremely progressive
and this is not to say that he has to
hold the same position that i do he
certainly does not there's a lot of
diversity in the jewish community about
this sort of stuff no matter how much i
think that that certain perspectives are
wrong and in some cases even anti-judaic
the point that's not the point i'm
making the point that i'm making is when
it comes to anti-semites they do not
care anti-semites don't care nether is
the left
it wasn't like trobide was like well he
attacked a progressive jewish synagogue
therefore
this is anti-semitism and and we should
and we should really pay attention to
the deep levels of anti-semitism that
paint all jews with the same brush et
cetera et cetera
there is not a lot of that there's not a
lot of that and the reason there's not a
lot of that is because two anti-semites
all jews are the same when it comes to
the intersectional pyramid which is
rooted in identity politics all jews are
the same as well
the reformed jews the same as the
orthodox jew the pro-israel jews the
same as the anti-israel jew they're all
the same
because again when it comes to which
group is a victimized group and which
group is a victimizing group which is
the only question that matters from the
progressive left jews are the
victimizing group
they somehow moved from being the
victimized group to the victimizing
group when they became wildly successful
and highly educated and when israel
became a successful state in the middle
east when that happened all sympathy
went out the window for all of this and
so it won't be on the front page anymore
it won't be on the front page this is
something by the way that the jews have
been lamenting for quite a while again
their jew the rate of hate crimes
against jews in 2020 2021 in new york
city was astonishing and bill de blasio
said he didn't even know what was
happening you didn't know what's
happening because the people doing it
weren't wearing maga caps alrighty
coming up
we'll get to joe biden uh he uh pulls
demonstrate that americans are not fond
there's a shock we'll get to that in
just one moment first when you bring a
product into your home you want to be
sure that your hard-earned money is
going to a brand that is as good as it
is humanly possible here at daily wire
we are working overtime to fight for our
values and over at naturally it's clean
they are working to keep your home clean
in the safest most effective way their
secret is powerful plant-based enzymes
nature's solution to cleaning when i say
powerful i'm talking about
hospital-grade enzyme cleaning power
they've got solutions for almost every
need in the house from the kitchen to
the bathroom to the laundry room
naturally it's clean has a specialized
formula to clean the area effectively
that products truly speak for themselves
they have the science to back it up and
to make things even better all of their
products are manufactured in the united
states and can ship directly to your
door for free i'm encouraging my
listeners to start with four of their
top products conveniently packaged
together in their daily wire essentials
kit for a limited time my listeners can
receive 15 off their order just enter
promo code ben at checkout when you
visit naturallyitsclean.com
try these incredible products in your
home today shipping is free everything
is made right here in the united states
again try our naturally it's clean daily
wire four pack today by going to
naturallyitsclean.com use promo code ben
to receive 15 off your purchase don't
delay make the smarter safer choice for
your home cleaning needs today with
naturally it's clean okay so brand new
poll out today and it shows that
according to cbs news
half of the respondents say they're
frustrated with joe biden
half
when asked in the poll how biden's
president he made them feel half of
respondents said they were frustrated
and disappointed 40 said his presidency
made them feel nervous a quarter of
respondents only said it made them feel
calm and satisfied 25 percent of
respondents said that joe biden's
presidency made them feel calm and
satisfied
those are hideous numbers
nearly 75 of those surveys said they
felt america was doing somewhat or very
badly in a general sense a majority of
people said they disapproved of the way
biden was handling the economy
immigration race relations crime
inflation policing and afghanistan
only 49 of americans even said he was
doing a good job of handling kovid 51
said he was doing a bad job handling
kovid only 45 percent of americans said
they believed that joe biden cared about
people like them 54
said they had serious doubts about all
of this
now by the way this is still a group of
people who are widely favorable to
democrats generally 61 percent told cbs
news they felt democrats were
concentrating on issues they cared about
53 said they even liked biden's
buildback better plan they just don't
like biden
they just think that biden is a bad
president who is bad at his job so
naturally instead of focusing in on the
things that americans actually care
about joe biden and company continue to
focus in on things that nobody cares
about namely this law that they keep
promoting that
if they do not rig all the voting
procedures from the top down federally
the republicans are going to steal every
election from here on in the problem is
they don't even have the support of
their own party james clyburn
the democratic representative from south
carolina one of the king makers in
congressional politics he said these
voting bills are now on life support
are the election reform bills dead do
you think
no i don't uh they may be on life
support uh but you know
john lewis and others did not give up
after the 64 uh civil rights act that's
why he got the 65 vote right there so
i'm gonna tell everybody we aren't
giving up we're gonna fight
and we plan to win because the people of
good will
are gonna break their silence
and help us win this battle
okay well um he's not going to win he
started ripping on uh joe manchin and
kirsten cinema you know they're
desperate when they start ripping on
their own party at this point they're
not even trying to woo mansion in cinema
they're just like those are bad people
good luck running against your own party
in a congressional election in about 11
months here
i know that um
these two democrats
have decided that it is much more
important for them
to protect the voting rights for the
minority on the senate floor
uh then to protect the voting rights of
minorities in this great country of ours
uh this great country the minorities
they made it possible for them to be in
the position that they're currently in
i mean this is wild stuff meanwhile
another congressman
adriano espaiot he says that there have
to be consequences for cinema what what
exactly are those consequences going to
be that she loses a primary in arizona
and then proceeds to lose like really
these people it's amazing they are
they're so in their own bubble that they
actually believe that this is somehow a
winning political strategy
there must be consequences
it's as simple as that
the president calls you
and you're gonna derail
his top one of his top
initiatives
our vision
of there's got to be consequences for
this
and you know they're very very precise
uh they they fit uh each state and each
leader in very precise ways
and so i'm sure once the consequences
are laid out for them there may be an
opportunity for meeting other minds
you know but there's got to be
consequences for this yeah what exactly
do those consequences look like
meanwhile the left wing of the
democratic party is openly now calling
kirsten cinema white supremacist so
here's msnbc's tiffany cross like really
go for this guys seriously i i'm more of
this more of this do it
cinema is a democrat but she is in many
ways upholding white supremacy you and i
both know what the filibuster was
originally used for i don't think i can
roll my eyes hard enough and you kind of
just want to say girl vibe girl bye keep
going with this seriously more more of
this the democrats are so disconnected
from the american people and then
they're surprised when they lose
meanwhile in virginia glenn youngkin
just took office glenn young immediately
got rid of all conversion
got rid of all critical race theory in
virginia law and there was some in
virginia law he immediately moved to get
rid of masking of children in his state
and this is what you guys brought about
and the democrats decided to go left you
will get republican governors in states
like virginia here's glen yonkin talking
about removing politics from the
classroom in his inauguration
we'll start where the future is
determined in the
classroom preparing virginia's children
preparing virginia's children to be
career and college ready
starting today we will raise standards
we will remove politics from the
classroom and refocus on essential
yes we will remove politics from the
classroom
and we will focus
on essential math and science and
reading
and we will teach all of our history the
good and the bad
this is amazing stuff right nothing he's
saying here should be remotely
controversial but it is
it is ralph northam the outgoing
governor in contrast he says that
anytime you mention critical race theory
it's because it's a dog whistle so glenn
junkin is like we will teach them all
the history good and bad and ralph
northam who used to dress up in a kkk
outfit or blackface
he's like yeah you know whenever you
mention crt it's because of racism and
jonathan k part at msnbc just nodding
along of course
critical race there is is nothing more
than a dog whistle
we don't teach critical race there it's
not a part of our curriculum in k-12
schools what it also says and perhaps
more importantly is that that anger and
fear are very strong emotions and you
know i think their campaign
was a lot based on that was out there
provoking fear and anger in people and
and they responded to it and and the
rest is history okay by the way i do
love the fact that this guy was called
upon by everyone to leave office after
the blackface kkk incident and uh then
he said yeah one of those people is
maybe i'm not sure which then he said
neither of those people is me but i'm
hunting the real one-armed man i know he
says he's a better person by the way
ralph northam
you know at the end of the day it was a
hurtful time i am glad that virginians
stuck with me i can tell you that i'm a
better person i certainly understand
racial issues much better than i did
prior to that uh episode and i and i
really think virginia more importantly
is is a better commonwealth of a
commonwealth that is more open more
inclusive and and really welcome new
people oh really because um they just
rejected your party on mass like they
just got rid of terry mcauliffe you left
office i love where he's like i'm
grateful that the people of virginia
stuck with me what choice did they have
dude unless you were going to resign no
one was impeaching you your own party
controlled the assembly
it is fairly incredible meanwhile glen
youngkin continues to say very obvious
things so he says listen we're going to
fight the masking of children and the
left is fighting him on this i it's
amazing
ask order arlington county public
schools essentially said it was going to
ignore the order is there anything
you're going to do to make that school
system comply well first of all we wrote
the order specifically to give all of
the school systems
basically eight days to get ready to
listen to parents
and the fact that that tweet came out
from arlington county within minutes of
my executive order what that tells me is
they haven't listened to parents yet and
if there's one thing that hopefully
everybody heard in november is it is
time to listen to parents man if he is
so right about this and this is good
honestly this is good politics okay what
he's talking about parents as an
interest group this is good politics it
used to be the parents weren't an
interest group you know why because
everybody sort of understood that
parents needed the ability to raise
their own children and that you did not
get to control and take away kids from
their parents and then indoctrinate them
and use them as little social
experiments and then the left leg went
completely overboard in every available
arena and the further left these folks
push the worse the backlash is going to
get
hey jen saki over at the white house she
tweeted out there hi there arlington
county parent here don't believe you are
glenn younkin but correct me if i'm
wrong thanks to aps virginia for
standing up for our kids teachers and
administrators and their safety in the
midst of a transmissible variant there
is no data that kids are dying in
outsized numbers from omicron okay
there's no data to support this
by the way there's still not a single
study that demonstrates that schools
that massed had a better record with
regard to delta than schools that did
not mask and that was the atlantic that
reported that
and and yet you have jen saki still
pushing this how crazy are they going
according to julie gunlock who is a
co-host over at wmal
she says in alexandria acp officials are
making the mass requirements more strict
that's alexandria alexandra city public
school officials are making mask
requirements more strict in light of
glenn youngkin's executive order no
exemptions all kids must either wear kn
95 masks all day or double mask with at
least one surgical mask
they're all crazy these people are all
crazy
this is nuts
am i kids at this point i believe have
all had omicron and guess what they're
all fine because they're all children it
turns out that children are made of
child and children are generally not
hurt by this virus and have not been the
entirety of the pandemic but they really
think that the more they control your
kids the better things are going to be
it's incredible and then they wonder why
they're unpopular
by the way we can also see the writing
on the wall when it comes to the left
and this sort of stuff because if you
thought it was bad with critical race
theory and trying to teach racial
essentialism to your children what
they're about to try and do the radical
left in the united states because
they're doing it in canada already to
teach your children gender theory and
try and pervert your kids
it's insane canada just passed a law
that they're calling an anti-conversion
therapy bill
okay and it's it's an insane law i mean
i'm reading the text of it it is nuts it
is nuts
and you know the left would love to
apply this here in the united states
i'll bring that to you in just one
moment because it really is not only
insane it's insulting it is child
destroying this law we'll get to that in
just one moment first
right now is a great time to re-fire
your mortgage like the best time ever to
re-fire a mortgage because the fed is
going to start raising rates soon when
that happens mortgage rates are going to
go up so if you've been thinking about
refined but you haven't pursued it now
would be the time you need to head on
over to american financing america's
home for home loans you'll get a free
mortgage review from a salary based
mortgage consultant so you can learn
about custom loan options before moving
forward no pressure no obligation no
upfront or hidden fees just a simple
conversation around your financial goals
and the many ways they can save you up
to a thousand dollars a month think
about that for a second
you could save up to 12 000 bucks a year
and tens of thousands long term simply
by refinancing your mortgage and if you
start right now you can close in as fast
as 10 days call 866
three hundred that's eight six six seven
two one thirty three hundred or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls182 334 and mls consumeraccess.org
go check them out right now
americanfinancing.net now is an amazing
time to refinance do not wait any longer
eight six six seven two one thirty three
hundred or visit
americanfinancing.net go check it out
right now all righty we'll get some more
in just one moment this canada law i
gotta talk about it because i think that
the left is gonna bring it to the united
states in short order i mean they
already are in places like jersey and
california first the first event for my
new book club guys it is this week it
takes place thursday 8 pm eastern 7 p.m
central each month i recommend a book
that is like one of the great books of
western civilization a great piece of
fiction this is this fiction book club
okay this month's book is george
orwell's 1984.
and i have a lot to say about 1984. i'm
sure you will too not only will the book
club hold you accountable for your
reading this year so that you will get a
lot done i mean i i'm telling you i have
the book list because i made it and let
me tell you if you stick with us you are
going to be so much better read by the
end of this year you'll also get
exclusive access to my personal notes
and analysis and then on the third
thursday of every month i will join a
daily wire i'll access members online
for an in-depth lecture and discussion
of each book you can ask me questions
directly right now get 25 off and all
access membership with code 1984 over at
dailywire.com subscribe again
you become part of that third thursday
book club right now become an all-access
member 25 off the code is 1984 because
that's the first book of our new book
club if you haven't already joined it's
not too late to sign up just head on
over to third thursdaybookclub.com you
can receive the materials you will need
to participate in my first members only
all access discussion don't forget head
on over to dailywire.com
subscribe join as an all access member
with 25 off using code 1984. i'm excited
to hang out and discuss orwell with you
this thursday january 20th 8 pm eastern
7 p.m central also i'm extremely excited
to announce the release of the poster
for our first original production here
at daily wire shut in a seat gripping
thriller that will be available to
stream in february just weeks away the
film follows the story of a young mother
barricaded inside a closet by her
violent ex-husband she has to use her
wits and she has to use her faith in
order to get out we seriously cannot
wait to share the finished final product
with you make sure to catch the final
trailer when it drops tomorrow if you're
planning on adding this terrifying
thriller to your queue and you want us
to keep making content to combat the
over politicized mainstream
entertainment complex go like and share
the trailer on youtube your support
makes an enormous difference
also as you know daily wire was one of
the first in the nation to file suit
against the biden administration's
tyrannical backs mandates and the
supreme court eventually ruled in our
favor tune in tomorrow night to catch an
all-new episode of backstage we'll
discuss the outcome of the supreme court
ruling and a lot more join me jeremy
boring michael moles matt walsh andrew
clavin tomorrow night seven o'clock
eastern 6 p.m central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel daily wire
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the
[Music]
nation so again what glenn youngkin ran
on in virginia and what he's going to
govern on is the idea that parents ought
to have control over how their kids live
their lives at least up to the point
where the kids are age of a majority
that used to be just how everyone
thought it is incredible to me that
there are so many folks on the left in
this country who believe that the right
is fighting the culture war you guys
declared a war and then we just said no
that's all that happened and you can see
that the march toward the progressive
left continues at pace in radical
fashion if you just want to see where
the left is going to go don't look to
just california or new jersey look to
canada so canada just put into effect a
law banning so-called conversion therapy
now
all these laws on conversion therapy in
places like california or new jersey
when you hear conversion therapy you
probably think of what used to actually
be called conversion therapy where you
would actually like tape electrodes to
people and then electrocute them if they
demonstrated any sign of same-sex sexual
attraction right you used to think of
like a form of torture that's what most
people think of when they think of
conversion therapy they generally don't
think of a person who goes into a
psychologist and says i'm struggling
with my sexuality and the psychologist
says let's talk about that
but but that is actually what is banned
in places like new jersey and california
you're supposed to only just affirm that
the person
is
has an alternative sexual orientation
okay in canada it just got a lot worse
in canada it's really really bad so
canada just passed a law that in the
united states would have to be found you
would imagine unconstitutional it's
insane but this is what the left would
like when it comes to how parents are
able to parent their kids with the new
law according to the new york times
canada's criminal code will prohibit
forcing someone to undergo conversion
therapy taking a minor abroad to take
part so you can't even take your kid
down to the united states to visit a
psychologist and profiting from
promoting or advertising the practice
violations can draw sentences of up to
five years in prison
the law was the canadian government's
second attempt last year to bring an end
to the quote-unquote widely discredited
practice and it's third since 2020 by
widely discredited do they mean talking
to a psychologist because again there's
a difference between a kid coming to you
and saying i'm struggling with my
sexuality and you talking to the kid and
taping electrodes to the kid okay but
but the the attempt to conflate all
conversion therapy with like the actual
horrible evil conversion therapy that
used to be practiced is ridiculous here
is what the canada law actually says i'm
going to read the text okay because
you'll see how insane this is here's
what the canada law actually prohibits
you ready
the defined conversion therapy which is
now banned and punishable by five years
in prison it means a practice treatment
or service designed to change a person's
sexual orientation to heterosexual
change a person's gender identity to
cisgender
cisgender means that your gender aligns
with your biological sex so in other
words if you have a kid and your kid
says
you know i think i might be a girl and
your kid's a boy and you take them to a
therapist and therapist says let's talk
about this because you're actually a boy
that therapist could now be in violation
of canadian law and go to jail for five
years
that's what they're doing in canada
if you bring a confused adolescent in
who's struggling with sexuality and
confusing thoughts and you say you know
you might be straight and you might grow
out of this that could be conversion
therapy notice by the way that it only
works one way and if you if you go to a
therapist in the and that and you say
you know i'm confused about my sexuality
i think i'm straight but i'm having some
some same-sex sexual attraction and the
therapist says you're you're gay just
like you're gay
and that is not conversion therapy under
the canada law and not punishable but if
you do the opposite if the person says
i'm confused you say you know what you
might be straight conversion therapy now
if conversion therapy it means to change
a person's gender expression so that it
conforms to the sex assigned to the
person at birth
so if a kid comes in we're talking about
children now if a parent brings a child
in and the child is cross-dressing
at the age of eight
and the therapist says you know you
might want to think about wearing
sex-appropriate attire
for a variety of reasons including your
own mental health this is now conversion
therapy punishable with jail time in
canada
it goes further if you if you get any
therapy in canada that is quote designed
with a practice designed to repress or
reduce non-heterosexual attraction or
sexual behavior reduce it not even
not even ban it not even convert
reduce it
which by the way is what most parents do
with their kids when they don't let them
watch pornography right like reducing
sexual
behavior in your like
you're not allowed to attempt to reduce
non-heterosexual behavior
i mean i do that with like like most
parents do that with sex with
heterosexual and non-heterosexual
behavior in their in their teenagers
like they don't want their teens having
sex but if you attempt to reduce the
sexual behavior in your therapist this
is conversion therapy
repress a person's non-cisgender gender
identity so okay so what this assumes is
that all of gender theory is not only
factually based it is biologically
ingrained
so if you are gay it's absolutely
biologically ingrained
also if you're a man in a woman's body
that's biologically ingrained but being
a man is not biologically ingrained and
being straight
is not biologically ingrained this is
this
this is what the canada law suggests
if you attempt to repress or reduce a
person's gender expression that does not
conform to the sexist signs of the
person at birth for greater certainty
this definition does not include a
practice treatment or service that
relates to the exploration or
development of an integrated personal
identity such as a practice treatment or
service that relates to a person's
gender transition and that is not based
on an assumption that a particular
sexual orientation gender identity or
gender expression is to be preferred
over another
by the way it doesn't just apply to the
therapist everyone who knowingly causes
another person to undergo conversion
therapy including by providing
conversion therapy to that other person
is guilty of an indictable offense and
liable to imprisonment for a term of not
more than five years or guilty of an
offense punishable on summary conviction
is that can mean a parent if you a
parent bring your child into a therapist
because your child
says that they believe that they're a
boy in a girl's body
if you bring that kid to a therapist
who's going to pursue watchful waiting
and not gender affirmation
you could go to jail though
and now the reason i bring this up is
because the left in the united states
wants exactly this
this is what the left in the united
states would like because this is the
natural outgrowth of their belief that
biology somehow
applies to both sex and gender but
gender is non-biological and also sex is
non-biological right none of this makes
any sense on an internal logical level
the only ideal here is that they get to
control the definition of your child
and it only runs in one direction
so this is now the law in canada
this is now part of
canada's chapter 24 criminal code
that's amazing amazing
okay and again this this will happen in
the united states sooner or later in
states like california and then you
wonder why people like glenn youngkin
are getting elected in virginia saying
that parents should have power to raise
their own children this is all part of
the broader cultural milieu in which we
live you guys declare a culture war
where you declare that biological sex is
not ingrained and that sexual
orientation is utterly unchangeable and
unchanging under all circumstances
right except if it moves in the
direction of straight to gay or straight
to bisexual or bisexual decay
right you say all of those things and
then you say that is enforceable by law
and then you wonder why parents are like
i'm not trusting my kid with any of you
people
i'm not trusting you on on race where
you say that racial essentialism is a
fundamental feature of life i don't
believe that i don't believe it when it
comes to your gender identity nonsense i
don't believe any of this stuff and i'm
not going to allow you to control how i
can how i raise my kids
this goes back to the general belief of
the left
that they care about your kids more than
you do because they know how to raise
your kids better than you do which is a
unique thing because i've yet to see
people who raise their kids this way
with
i would say highly well adjusted kids on
average this does not seem like a recipe
for the success of the mental health of
your child to raise them gender neutral
and suggest that all sexual behavior is
equally
worthwhile
like i've yet to see how this is a
healthy way of raising children but
apparently it's so healthy it needs to
be mandated by law in canada and
punishable by fine if you violate it
man the parental backlash in this
country is going to be so strong and it
is well deserved and it is absolutely
coming it is absolutely coming and again
glenn younkin is one aspect of that
ronda sanchez is another keep going with
this guys
keep going
okay meanwhile
the the
president of the united states continues
to
flounder when it comes to omicron so
omicron
continues to rush through the united
states
on average it's not killing all that
many people because the infection
fatality rates for omicron are pretty
low but now you have the the cdc
recommending that everybody wear n95 or
canon 95 masks forever
the level of control these folks wish to
cram down on you truly is an amazing
amazing thing
and and the way that they're going to do
this is they're going to try and scare
you i'm not sure why their their
strategy to scare you is is worthwhile
but they are going to try to scare you
the associated press says get ready to
learn more greek letters scientists warn
that omicron's whirlwind advance
practically ensures it won't be the last
version of the coronavirus to worry the
world
every infection provides a chance for
the virus to mutate omicron has an edge
over its predecessors it spreads way
faster
experts don't know what the next
variants will look like or how they
might shape the pandemic they say
there's no guarantee the sequel's
vomicron will cause milder illness or
existing vaccines will work against them
okay well isn't that a case for everyone
to sort of get
omicron isn't that the case get the mild
version not the more severe version and
get some natural immunity but we can't
pursue this logically instead we just
have to scare the hell out of you
good luck with that all right we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content coming up soon as the
matt wall show it airs 1 30 pm eastern
be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is palvo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show